15 years since you all started keeping
up with Kardashians
15 years I know I know
it's a it's a lot I mean could you have
dreamed this did you drink this like the
life that you and your family have built
it's amazing it's really amazing Kim
you're doing amazing
Kim would you stop taking pictures of
yourself your sister's going to jail
let me tell you something I think one of
the things about this is it does take a
village I mean you could be handed every
opportunity in the world and unless you
have the exact perfect dream team in
place to execute what it is that has
been handed to you as a gift in front of
you and to be able to have control over
your own destiny and try to make things
happen and I have never met five girls
in my son these people these beautiful
little Souls who have the best work
ethic of anybody I've ever met in my
life anybody I've never seen anything
like it and it's almost like the perfect
storm you know because you could have
said oh here go do this and you know
here's here's this opportunity I don't
know if you've heard this a lot but one
of the things that I really because I've
been watching you know keeping up and
then now the new show pretty much since
you guys started one of the things I
really love about the new show it seems
more documentary style like it feels
right yeah it feels like they were just
kind of hanging it's different it's
another chapter I think I loved
obviously Keeping Up with the
Kardashians so much that was our baby
and it's where we started we'll speak in
a way as if like you should know better
and guess where I learned it
yeah and that was you know 15 years
almost of doing that show with all those
people and that's who we miss the most
is you know our family our crew that was
such a sad thing but you know saying
goodbye but I Hulu has been a dream it
feels growing and it feels like we've
evolved it's a little more in an
elevated space where we are now in our
lives and I think that I say that in in
a way like it's just evolved and
followed us into even another new
chapter you know so that's really been
so much fun and I also feel like you see
something faster yeah you know so a
month or two out rather than you know
five or six months and that's the beauty
of being on a streaming uh Network and
there's nobody better than Disney
literally happiest place on earth
when you do shoot and then you have like
how do you decide then okay well this is
old news this doesn't matter or we keep
this this is still relevant I think you
know they've just done such a good job
of editing the shows and getting them
out there and I we really hadn't in this
go around have to really even think
about that to be honest I'm not gonna go
through this again I know the right
attorneys this time I know exactly what
to do this time I'm not going to let
this happen to me again I think Kim is
really good at
um you know uh zeroing in on things like
that those kind of issues that might
seem stale or you know not relevant
anymore who cares or you know but so far
it's been a breeze and it's been really
great working with them this is a new
kind of swaddle and it doesn't make the
crunchy noise it's just silence
and it's really
all about the best that you make out of
your opportunities that are given to you
and that you're blessed with and that's
what I think makes the difference when
we first started I thought oh gosh will
they pick us up for season two wow and
we were you know working and they did uh
in the middle of the season one and they
said good news bad news good news is
you've been picked up for season two
right bad news is you don't get a break
I knew you guys were coming to film and
I was like I can't have a million dishes
in the sink we had to learn a lot about
you know a lot of 12 or 18 hour days and
shooting every single thing we were
doing before we you know kind of got
into a Groove so it was a lot of hard
work that's why you're here that's why
God put you here to raise kids and have
a family and be with each other and
that's what life is all about anything
you change along the way or is the
journey what makes the chapters are
beautiful I'm sitting exactly here with
you today and this is exactly where I'm
supposed to be sitting and I live my
life like that look back never ever if I
looked back and thought about it too
much
I'd need another Martini really quickly
I love it we just keep on going
[Music]